un tiro nuovissimo bene l'idea del video
di oggi mi è venuta perché stava
rovistando nel cassettone di camera mia
dove butto tutte le cose che non so dove
mettere che creano disordine e ho
trovato queste carte le ho ritrovate e
ho detto facciamo assolutamente subito
il video
indovina lo con delle muse ma in che
senso indovinano con delle muse
spieghiamo meglio come funzionano queste
carte allora sono 56 56 kart aspettate
che perdo i pets e dove qui davanti
nella diciamo riquadro già hanno appunto
troviamo le emoji dietro c'è un riguardo
in un riquadro rosso dove troviamo
diciamo la soluzione del rebus quindi
cosa significano quelle moggi messe
insieme
ho pensato di fare una challenge per
fare una challenge che mi metto quale
indovino da sole ci vuole un minimo
un'altra persona no ed è qui che farei
entrare lo special guest di oggi e do
che da dietro la telecamera
la videocamera mi arriva davanti per
fare come questa challenge bellissima
dove ovviamente ci sarà un vincitore
perché spieghiamolo meglio come
giocheremo ad occhi chiusi ognuno di noi
pescherà dalmazzo che avrà in mano
l'altro una carta e la consegnerà
all'altra persona
ovviamente chi le vende minare vedrà
solo un riquadro giallo
chi invece c'è dietro la carta vedrà la
risposta quindi il riquadro rosso e
ognuno di noi a disposizione può
chiedere per ogni diciamo carta da
indovinare un consiglio già le regole
non le sappiamo è l'arma in più ognuno
di noi avrà a disposizione due aiuti da
casa mi sembra di essere un po al
milionario questi due aiuti da indovino
con il quale la sala mano
due minuti da casa che possono essere o
una chiamata o un messaggio a una
persona un amico fidanzato eccetera
eccetera oppure chiedono ai propri
follower su instagram con la boxe delle
domande partiamo subito allora tieni le
card pari e dispari non facciamo queste
cose da tantissimi anni vaio pari ok
[Risate]
quindi inizi tu a indovinare ok ok
allora aspetta facciamola vedere
ovviamente a tutti guarda allora un up
on è un'onda dopo guarda veramente la
fortuna gira male è proprio la pe non
puoi dire a te on
eccetera eccetera come si diceva in
inglese di beyoncé è indovinata subito
difficilissima sibio si possa vedere ai
neve scimmiette è un film no è un gruppo
musicale artic ma anche se è tutto ok
stefano era un bambino un anello un
dragon ball aspetta no non è la mia
carica
no no no no no lie dei fan o l'hai detta
la ghetta sbagliata dragonball o lei ha
sbagliato 21 ora le regole levy ha
spiegato all'inizio la dc sbagliata dei
sbagliato era facilissima pure questa
immaginavo infatti ha detto draghi è
facile allora ma questo facilissima
farci di facilissima dai su e quello che
penso io è uno dei miei film preferiti
poi light art
az devo farla vedere allora è facile se
sai la risposta no però posso dire in
realtà secondo me è facile guarda è
facile anche la cosa potrebbe essere il
titolo di un film non te lo posso dire
perché vuoi chiedere solo una volta la
categoria one way che cos'è una canzone
ragazzi era facile qui potevi chiedere
l'aiuto te lo diciamo subito one
direction cioè dai raga facili e vabbè
che centra però uno e freccia era
direzione queste facilissimo c'è un
altro vini ma vabbè ragazzi la bella e
la bestia e qui ci sarà canzone
something suite e non sky ma ti vuol
bene vi fossero altri acquisti e il
socio quando vuoi a dire sì a te questa
non ne ho la più pallida idea non
guardare due uomini e un bambino
i due genitori e mezzo
cherie quasi two and a half men due
uomini e mezzo prima non lo so cultura
generale andrò a vederlo questa qui
vabbè allora questa ma posso vedere
direi aspetto direi facili na non
facilissima ma fascino faide riguarda
letteralmente proprio hicks man hicks e
tre uomini che è man facile
spetta facciamo perché devo far vedere
questa è bellissima questa la so red hot
chili peppers canta una canzone dire
dott
la robello prossimamente in concerto ma
questa non facilissima vedeva vedere
come dentro pure aereo letto più cibo si
bed and breakfast allora ti faccio il
mio in una versione tito e ti do bajona
qaeda gli era già allora aereo letto è
un'app per bimbi è più o meno bed and
breakfast non era difficile cioè facile
facilissima guarda tirare un telefilm
non te lo posso dire ma più di tre
secondi non ci puoi mettere da easy
proprio easy house of cards come
capitano sempre quelle un po benefici
difficilissimo queste grigie allora no è
molto attuale come carta america uomo
troppo
chrome american trumpet no no no di
american trump e così vale ragazzi
american tra roberts io farei una serie
tv con questo con questo anno dal canto
alber domani prima puntata esatto
trombetta americana benissimo allora
microfono note musicale singin in the
rain anche qual è però in che senso
un valido le voci sono molto belle
secondo me facilissima guns and roses
pistole e rose gruppo musicale
ok difficile la sete lo farà vedere neve
e un bambino e neve questa è chiaro ti
piaccio
sto andando avanti a 700 aiuti che gli
ho dato così detto più ghiaccio snow ice
una canzone
amo letterale ice child ice ice baby
food un giunture dumitru
questa qui è facile da les moulineaux
così tanto è pugno e asso pugno fiore
principale era fight club
scardigno ma poi face to the mic club
scusatemi club questo adesso adesso vedi
vai non facile di più
per leone lion king inglese dai un king
and queen diventeremo è una zona che va
da cosa dai anche questa con te secondi
vado alla ricerca di nemo per prego un
bicchiere di vino è un distributore dai
ti aiuto ad una persona vin diesel bravo
dire chiedilo aiuto perché questo
veniamo subito facile la canzone no
baila dance slot pci no non è non è non
è nessuno di queste parole chi le scrive
qualcosa non è un detto una cultura
generale cultura pop e tac
e la tua band ai ragazzi capiva il
sedere ma dai su e giù da non è vero
adesso arriviamo beach boys
questa è la verità e boys gruppo
famosissimo anni 80
vabbè questa fase è facile facile
prevedere orange is new black yak facile
è facile bello bello
cos'è una canzone più o meno un gruppo
chiedero a casa c'è perché questa vera
inter
allora deciso di mandarla a un mio amico
andrea andrè mi devi aiutare in questo
gioco devo indovinare la parola che si
cela dietro questo rebus e mi devi
aiutare me facile di così tratto è
online tra l'altro perché stavo per dire
che gestiamo quaino dopodomani star
essendo un audio era facile infatti non
capivo perché avendo grassi per ora non
facilissimo crederà ma potreste
arrivarci
ho capito ho capito con la croce a sean
connery è il titolo cavola inghilterra
avrò non mi viene
io chiedo l'aiuto allora lo sto
chiedendo ai miei mariners quindi ho
scritto è un film quale c'è chi jury lo
so qual è non mi viene il titolo proprio
ai famosissimi cioè la tv che il
sentiero e probabilmente non lascia
nessuno per ora di ben 17 giusto perché
hai fatto che la faccia però si chiama
così james bond
e vabbè dai buona comunque ragazzi in
jonas italy neri scorso la prima
guardate prima risposta 007 top è facile
american pie perché così fare lì a lui e
campa la mamma di stifler te ne ricordi
questa probabilmente cosa cosa dai not
rouse no ha sbagliato cavodotto room che
guarda un po top gun
speravo che questa e lo mettesse in
difficoltà
bella questa vedere and buy back case e
bambini un po biondi un po ma proviamo
nei favori e fa c'è una cosa che può
sapere tipo salvo della mandiamo chiedo
aiuto a casa aveva una cosa un po anni
90 barra 2000 e nell'ambito di un aiuto
non andrà mai musicali per ora non e
smog per ora a brain storming ci sta
pensando
ok non è più online
esatto non è molto collaborativo anche
divertito dimmi subito che devo vincere
mettiamo un po di ansia giustamente se
no magari perché lui non sa ideale per
una idea del video che stiamo girando
quindi magari risponde bene salvo non
risponde quindi a questo punto se sente
io la sposterei sulle domande
instagram perché sono più persone
presenti
allora per adesso ho alcune risposte ma
in particolare una mi ha fatto capire
che sono una cretina perché era non
facile di più e cioè facciamo rivedere
sono ovviamente i backstreet boys in
caso il telefono vediamo ma chiave un
pullman a diego subito ottenuto è un
fattore mi hai dato un aiuto
infatti sono proprio brava ma quando
allora vi posso dire che uno dei miei
film preferiti che ha fatto lui american
beauty bellissimo mi è piaciuto
tantissimo risposta kevin spacey che tra
l'altro è abbastanza difficile perché
era ki won questo avanti ki won spacey
cioè proprio le parole cos'è il mac
pollo hamburger pizza e videogiochi
giocare videogiochi mangiando certo no
allora aiuto è un film queste cosa sono
cibo cibo perché
food games cielo hunger games questa
grazie lametta qui grazie ultima ultima
carta cos'è questo video giochi tipo
cioè successo i famosissimi visconti
successo il sesso lo devi vedere più
metaforico sì la somma che vi aiuto
suisse che non è ancora che essa si sta
muovendo virano domanda si v
un rebus rebus che telefilm ancora che
lo aiuto è tra l'altro allora mi è
arrivata una risposta game of thrones
sembra un po strano e game of thrones
scusami game il trono non c'era il trono
le mose è il trono per eccellenza che
abbiamo tutti a casa è il signor sesso
quindi game of thrones
allora adesso non ci resta che contare
via quando non barare
allora ognuno le conta ma non dice il
numero 1 2 3 diciamo 123 18 pari non è
vero arriva dai ragazzi questa cosa è
allucinante
io l'ho vinta che fossi in vantaggio su
anche io credevo di essere in vantaggio
io poi cosa non gioco da vincere
l'incoronazione aspetta aspetta di
quelli allora ragazzi questa è
un'incoronazione per la parità mi sembra
giusto così alle regine la corona e air
e la corona forma di cuffia io direi che
così possiamo concludere il video vi
ricordo se non l'avete ancora fatto e se
vi è piaciuto questo video di iscriverla
canale di cliccare sulla campanella
vicino al tasso d'iscrizione per
ricevere le notifiche tutte le volte
pubblico primo video e di seguirmi su
tutti gli altri social facebook e
instagram e tic toc e dovete seguire
anche su instagram è da lui si chiama
eduardo 40 quindi seguiteci vi mando vi
mandiamo un bacione speriamo che il
video vi sia piaciuto
e chi lo sa magari ne faremo un altro
con cui si intitola rivincita certo
perché la parità e bella siamo contenti
ma noi vogliamo di più
vogliamo tutto e ce l'andremo a prendere
al prossimo
[Musica]